tu es un vrai petit voyage du voide
époque toujours apte à tirer des angles
tu vas faire quoi maintenant d'un nouvel
endroit nouvelle vie non
tu fais quoi plus tard j'irai dormir
d'accord c'est comme ça que tu invites
in fillot dit que j'étais en train de
vie tel est lé mais qu à charge et tout
ça mais qui me qu'ils évitent bien
quelqu'un qui se balade avec plus d'un
million de notre marchandise je veux que
vous retrouviez mon stock
la ferme combien de fois on va devoir
venir te voir on peut pas faire affaire
comme ça on a besoin de temps tu t'es
dans une embuscade maintenant vous allez
retourner chercher l'argent écoute il
fallait que quelqu'un s'oppose enfin à
ces types quelqu'un devait le faire et
tu l'as fait
j'ai un message pour toi tu es un amor
arrêt
les italiens il connaît les russes il
connaît tout le monde n'est pas prêt de
revoir net par ici
tu plaisantes et pas
russie près les très libre et c'est pour
ça que je t'aime et mickey et c'est quoi
ton préoccupé des ruses pour toi
quelqu'un nous prend pour cibles
quoi qu'il aura permis de caler tout ce
qui te pousse est maintenant tu sais ce
qu'ils te reste à faire
ono est devenu incontrôlable c'est un
chien de combat il faut qu'on fasse
quelque chose et si on est les prochains
[Musique]